saluons va commencer cette vidéo par un
petit rituel qu'on va tenir sur les 31
prochains jours je vous donne d'abord la
solution de l'énigme de la veille si
vous n'avez pas vu la vidéo d'hier avec
l'énigme d'hier regardez là tout de
suite parce que là maintenant je vais
donner la réponse pour trouver la
réponse il fallait simplement retourner
le dessin des places de parking et là on
se rend compte que ce sont pas les
places 16 06 68 etc
mais les places 86 87 88 89 et c'est
donc la voiture se gare sur la place
numéro 87 c'était donc ça et je pense
que beaucoup d'entre vous l'ont trouvée
et donc nouvelle énigme la numéro deux
on est samedi temps en temps le samedi
je vous ferais plutôt un défi genre un
défi qu'on peut faire dans un bar pour
se faire payer un coût un défi à faire
un repas aujourd'hui c'est le cas c'est
un samedi défi vous demander à quelqu'un
de mettre une pièce de monnaie sur la
table et de recouvrir la pièce avec une
tasse opaque comme ceux ci et vous
annoncer que vous allez être capable de
récupérer la pièce de monnaie dans votre
main sans que vous ne touchiez jamais la
tasse en clair vous ne toucherez jamais
la tasse même par contact indirect
d'ailleurs vous n'avez pas le droit de
prendre deux objets pour soulever la
tasse par exemple vous ne toucherez
jamais la tasse et pourtant vous êtes
capable de récupérer la pièce cherchez
bien comment réaliser ce défi il ya une
solution qui existe et qui est efficace
dans 100% des cas je vais moi même bu
quelques bières à l'oeil grâce à ce défi
si vous avez trouvé la réponse surtout
la mettez pas dans les commentaires vous
pouvez en parler mais mettez pas la
réponse y laisser les autres chercher
par contre dès que vous allez trouver la
solution mais tu es un pouce en l'air
pour qu'on puisse voir tout de suite le
pourcentage de personnes qui ont trouvé
la solution par rapport au nombre de
vies profiter du soleil passer un bel
été n'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant
de partir parce que le mental box est
une vidéo par jour pendant un an donc
rendez vous demain à 11h ciao